call me dude Z well I love your
impression of Hulk Hogan oh well thank
you very much see that's nice I love
your impression of Hulk Hogan so much
that I'm going to do your impression of
Hulk Hogan for the rest of this episode
see one of the things that that AIS can
do is they can do uh they can you know
well shoot I mean look at the [__]
thing we did with Tom Brady spit out a
one-hour special of Tom Brady stand up
and it sounded just like yeah whatever
well let me tell you something will and
Chad last week I asked you to leave your
home to view the feature film The Super
Mario Brothers movie dude
that sounds like you ah no not exactly
nice work D but not exactly exactly but
close enough well hold on a second Chad
hold on
um it sounds a little like me sure